you know what I think is so exciting
about creating a game for people is you
you are able to put the spectator in
this world
to the original it's like Frankenstein
or Dracula Wolf Man - snow doesn't see
what I had before after someone in the
middle I remember having a conversation
with the outfit and I said we're doing a
classic you know he says yeah we sure
are
1984 is I what he was made 30 and 35
years of 79 1979 now Jesus Christ you
cannot walk away from video game you're
just not walking away either you're
there you're married in games you do it
from different perspectives so I mean
maybe I get to be a badass and survive
who knows the idea of putting you in the
movie as it were I think is is there not
film directors but they know what we all
want which is to be immersed in this
world
she never landed on this damn ball me
and Parker we told Brett over and out
Jesus you took your time shed off my
side of the system I'm a sitting duck
here
it's what you don't see that rings your
imagination and that's really your
imagination is much more terrifying it's
not a really pleasant world for humans
to be in and it certainly becomes a lot
more unpleasant when the alien is in
your midst
[Music]